if the tweet says losing my [ __ ] mind
at this kwibi show where actual emmy
winner
rachel bras bras 'no not Brosnahan yeah
plays a woman obsessed with her golden
arm the whole premise of this show is
just Thanos but a woman home and every
gold disease watch that being a verse
[Laughter]
Trinidad James yeah some rapper needs to
use that what what could it be something
something all with ease I got pulmonary
Gold disease no that's Eminem style yeah
anyway this is like Goldmember dude like
no I can't take off my golden arms
whatever she wants that's a man who's
been in a relationship longer than four
years
characters alright you've been dating
for four years go she has to remove the
GALT whatever she wants happy wife happy
life I can't take off me Golden Arm I
can't get rid of me going on and take
off me golden arm they're always after
me golden up they're always after we
golden arm quick there's the lady with
the Golden Arm
oh you've got to give me your golden
hour
this guy's got a sick beard just take
the [ __ ] off lady
if she's dying because of this arm she's
literally dying because he won't take
off her [ __ ] golden arm she's gonna
turn to gold man she's gonna turn into
an Emmy that's what this whole thing is
a metaphor for her career when she turns
into a [ __ ] dam I take back
everything I said about kwibi [ __ ]
rules you're loving this [ __ ] right [ __ ]
rules
but it only works for this kind of
storytelling so maybe that's it it just
has to be storytelling with no need for
depth or any technical aspects it's just
100% character-driven right is this not
comedy is this not a sketch no [ __ ] no
man oh my god that's awesome they
straight up got daytime soap opera
directors and said alright what can you
do with twenty million dollars guys I
just I've got just the thing
trust me I've got a golden idea he goes
on he opens the chest pulls it out I've
been waiting to use you my whole life
hold on dude all right I'm gonna smash
play on this yes ma'am
[Music]
when I die is this supposed to be some
will bury you is this supposed to be
some commentary on like consumerism I
don't know man I don't know and how
we're obsessed with shiny objects may be
stupid I gotta see you said you're not
inspired to open kwibi what about now
[ __ ] I am now yeah this is the best
[ __ ] on kwibi dude the scrolling the
scrubbing is vertical that feet hold
that not intuitive is that I don't know
man I kind of like it I kind of like it
how because you you can the idea is
you're you're peeing sitting down okay
and you can you can you know keep keep
control at the left hand left hands
available
you know if the stream is getting too
crazy you can reach down and right hand
you can always keep on the phone and
scroll up and down you already you know
you're already cruising with the thumb
you just very quickly just what you say
yeah okay I see you're thinking
functionally yeah yeah yeah but maybe
for some practice maybe yeah welcome to
the UX podcast but we talked about all
things digital and UX we talked about
design patterns know this clip is too
good
dare I say it [ __ ] is gold nice I need
to take it I need to take a seat with
that one that was bad
you